[Music]
are you honest
let me ask the question a different way
have you ever told a lie
you can see the problem we've all told
little white lies
some of us have even told more than that
this unfortunately is more pervasive
than we think
it's called ethical fading and it's
something that dr lenny wong has spent
many years studying he spent 20 years in
the military studying
why good cultures turn bad and i
actually learned about
ethical fading from him in a world in
which everybody's trying to get ahead
and sometimes we do so
by doing things that are ethically
questionable
the question is what can we do about it
this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
lenny so good to see you good to see you
simon you and i met a
bunch of years ago i heard you speak at
a conference and
you were the one who introduced me to
this concept of ethical fading
which i ended up writing about in the
infinite game correct
this concept i find so fascinating and
unfortunately the reason i think it's
fascinating is it's pervasive in our
society today
correct me if i get this wrong but
ethical fading is the phenomenon
where a large group of people a culture
of an organization
make unethical decisions believing
that they are well within their own
ethical framework they don't believe
they've done anything wrong
and yet from an outsider in it is so
obvious
that something has gone haywire for
example a
pharmaceutical company that owns the
patent to an essential drug
and will raise the price 500 600 800
percent a thousand percent
though not illegal highly unethical
and the people inside that organization
will shrug their shoulders and say
there's nothing wrong with
it right it's temporarily suspending
any notion of right or wrong and it's
very closely related to moral
disengagement
so the ethical fading came from a
professor of psychology named anten
brunsel
it's basically setting aside the ethical
dilemma because you just say well
there's no ethics involved in this this
is just a
decision it's a business decision it's a
cost-benefit analysis or whatever but
there are no ethics involved in this and
so
we could just move on and make the
decision and 10 bressel calls it a form
of of self-deception which i found very
interesting as well
not only is that you said it's it's
amazing that's so pervasive
to me it's amazing that we don't even
know it that it's so persuasive but we
refuse to look it in the face
because i think it collapses so much
of what humans do and we rationalize
away
and it's an ugly thing to look at to
admit
that no you just told a lie and you just
don't want to admit it
right some of the things that go into
that self-deception we have
all done let's be honest we've all done
it right it's so pervasive
so for example everyone's doing it i had
no choice
that's what my boss wanted me to do and
this is my favorite one
it's the system right so
in an organization where all of the
pressures upon someone
is to do things that are in
self-interest of the organization
so they would hit a number at an
arbitrary date all the incentives
pressure them to hit that number so both
incentives and disincentives
massive amounts of them are thrust upon
a person because a few people at the top
have thought that this number is more
important than anything else
and at the rank and file what ends up
happening is they do anything to appease
their boss
fit the incentive program avoid getting
in trouble or worse
one person does something highly
unethical like at wells fargo bank when
thousands of people open millions of
fake bank accounts
and other things it started i assume
because one or two people tried it
and somebody went good job and then
everybody else did it right
right and so those cases it's the system
and really what we're expecting that
person 14 levels below
is not for them to tell the truth in the
first place because we want them to lie
to us
do you equate ethical fading and lying
as synonymous for me
it's the easiest example but i think
ethical fading really
is the ability to develop hypocrisy in
our own minds and live with it
how do we live with ourself and the
answer is ethically faded
i've been in the army in uniform for 20
years now as a civilian for 20 years
and so in the army you view yourself as
a moral upright
cut above and to hear ourselves
admit it to lying that really goes
against who we think we are
ethical fading allows us to live with
who we really are
and who we think we are and this goes
way back
to what jesus accused the pharisees of
doing it's like you guys are hypocrites
because you're telling everyone to do
this and when you really look at it
you're not doing it yourselves
and so it's very human but it's very
ugly and that's why i say
especially in my organization the
military we don't like to look at it
because it really attacks who we say and
think we are
and perhaps the greatest form of honesty
is to look at oneself and say i was
dishonest
correct but look at all the creeds and
codes that we have
that say you will never lie cheat or
steal your word is sacred
and it is but we're also human
how do you have an inspirational
aspirational
organization and yet you fill it with
humans that's what's really hard so we
can either tell everyone
you're really not as good as you think
you are or we could say you're the best
but let's ignore all this humanness that
creeps out every once in a while
yeah how did your interest in this
show up so i did a study back in
the early 2000s with a friend named
steve garris and it's called lying to
ourselves
where we address this going on in the
army and saying we have a problem
i looked at all the requirements we
placed on junior officers and
what we discovered was junior officers
have about 256
available training days and when you add
up every single requirement
that we put on them it equates to about
297 training days
and so it's physically impossible to
accomplish everything that the army
tells them to do
in the amount of time we give them to do
it how can we ever develop innovative
officers
when all they do is run around doing
what we tell them to do
but what always bothered me when i wrote
that study is if they can't literally do
it
in the time period we give them what are
they reporting
and so that haunted me for about a
decade and so i was sitting in my
co-author's office steve garris and i
said hey steve i got a
research project that i'd like to work
on he says what i said i think even
though we don't think we're lying we're
lying to ourselves he says i don't know
what you're talking about i am an honest
person
you ask my wife one thing she knows i
will never lie to her
and he's typing away his computer i said
i think there's something there
are you listening to me and says yeah i
remember this thing he keeps typing away
what are you doing and he says
i'm filling in all the mandatory
training we're supposed to do saying i
did it
and he was sitting at his computer
filling it all out and i said
that's exactly what i'm talking about
how can you sit there and do that
and yet we tell ourselves we're honest
people at the army war college
we have a lesson on ethics
and ethical fading we always talk about
it
but finally we are confronting it up in
our face that this happens
so this got reinforced i was talking to
a civilian friend of mine and he's
talking about his wife had to move up in
the organization because they had fired
somebody
and i said what'd they fire him for they
said well the person was
falsifying training rosters they were
saying people were attending training
who never did
and it made me realize we have really
developed a culture where ethical fading
is
pervasive it's allowed it's not talked
about
and it's impacting all aspects of our
life so
that's how we got started on this so the
fun example that i
talked about where i suffered ethical
fading
was i had a job where out of the blue
the company announced that we had to
start filling out timesheets
now i worked 100 on one account what do
you need to know
i know yeah you know so we had to hand
them in weekly
i never handed my time sheets on time
because i'm just terrible at that kind
of stuff
and so i would get in trouble so i would
sit down
for the entire week on friday morning
and i would fill out my timesheets
right in at nine out at five now i often
showed up
at whatever time and i always left later
but who cares
so in nine out five in nine out five in
nine out five
done and i think maybe i was two weeks
or three weeks behind
because you know i'm late so i'm filling
out two or three weeks worth of time
sheets here
in out in and out exactly the same time
every single day
i go to my boss because somebody has to
sign off on my timesheets
and he looks at them and he says boy
you're a very consistent worker aren't
you
basically pointing out to me that he
knows i fudged my sheets
and then he signs them right and we go
about our day
and that's where i look at the
organizations organizations create the
systems that everyone looks at and says
that system
isn't real so we create in our mind an
imaginary
line that says that's the fake world
that's the world we lie to
because someone came up with that system
that process that they really don't want
truth
they just want you to fill it out so all
columns are lined up that's where
organizations fall in and
encourage ethical fading we're not
really looking for the truth what we
really want to know is
simon did you put in an honest work week
yeah i did okay here fill out these
timesheets and lie away
right just reinforce the narrative that
we all want to believe
language is a big deal here as well it's
the overuse of euphemisms
right like in the united states torture
violates our values we would never
ever torture but enhanced interrogation
is extremely helpful
right or in the business world or in our
personal world
we would never spy on our customers but
data mining so helpful so valuable
right or even referring to human beings
as data points
right and the overuse of this language
where we literally dehumanize people
so we can distance ourselves from the
impact we may have on their lives
or we create euphemisms so we can again
create distance from the impact of our
decisions
because it just makes it easier right
because we don't like the harsh reality
of
to say well i lied so instead we heard
things like i'm just telling them what
they want to hear
well you're lying or the best one i
heard is that's not lying
that's good leadership i had my boss
when i was starting to do this study
came in and said so what's the study
you're working on i told him and uh he
says i don't know what you're talking
about i just don't see any evidence of
that
and so i said well wait a minute
according to the regulations i'm
supposed to get quarterly counseling
from you
on how i'm doing we've never done that
and yet every annual
counseling there's all these little
dates with your initials by it on how we
met and talked
i said we never met and talked what do
you call that and he says
that's not lying that's protecting my
boss and so
we don't like to hear those words lying
or i
didn't tell the truth and even when we
came to write up the study
it was hard to write down that we lie
so we were even looking for different
ways of saying lying because it's such a
harsh in-your-face word that makes us
confront
the evilness that we all know so here's
the uncomfortable question
is it ever okay to lie i think the
answer is is
no then you have to ask the secondary
question
are you ever boxed in where you have to
lie
not that it's okay i think that's what
we have to transmit is that we're human
and so it's not like the organization
is trying to teach these people to be
perfect
because we can't expect you to be
perfect because you're human
so we understand that yes there will be
times that you will lie but we want you
to know
you should never have to lie i'm
uncomfortable with this idea of
the box because who sets the edges
exactly right and that's the problem so
there was a study done
about child development and they did
these wonderfully innovative experiments
to show the development of a child's
mind
of which one of them was learning to lie
because little kids don't lie
right they tell you everything it's a
fault
and the point that was made in the study
was that lying
is an important social convention
and the experiment that they set up was
a mother
and her friend who are both in on the
experiment meet for lunch
and the mother brings her little kid
and the friend gives the mother a gift
and the mother says thank you i love it
and the kid immediately says no you
don't you hate it
and the mother says no i love it and the
kid says no you have
one just like this at home and you
always talk about how much you hate it
and the kid hadn't learned yet this
social convention
that we have to tell what is a lie
in order to not hurt someone's feelings
right
right but i think the ideal in that is
to tell the child it's never good to lie
but mom you just lied
i know and i wish i didn't have to lie
so i called bs all right ending
conversation what else what else you
want to talk about simon
wait no no listen i'll tell you why
because what you said i wish i didn't
have to but i do
that's exactly it but that's the problem
lenny which is
if we could all get away with saying i
wish i didn't have to but i do it at
least makes us aware of the lie
but then we go right back to where we
started which is i have to get ahead i
got to put food on the table that's what
my boss wants me to do everybody's doing
it i'm going to get in trouble
right it's the first inch of that
slippery slope that you start sliding
down wait wait
what if we find new ways to tell the
truth
as opposed to lying because look your
work
screwed with my head lenny like you keep
me up at night
right you're the reason go back to the
example of the gift
fine i'll give it to you the mistake she
made
was saying i love it right
thank you so much for thinking of me no
issue
oh you didn't have to give me a gift
this is so kind of you
the mistake she made was i love it
the effusive thanks for the generosity
and thinking of her was where she should
have stopped
yeah i'm not going to ever give you a
gift first of all simon
here but yes
but simon what if the person says did
you like
the gift right now you play a game of
obfuscation which is unfair
great i got you your gift did you like
it i mean this happened to me
where i went to see a friend's play
and it was easily the worst thing i've
ever seen in my life
i mean it was abominable right and
i meet my friend backstage right after
the play she's still in
costume she's still in makeup the
adrenaline is still pumping
and of course the first question out of
her mouth is
what did you think
right now she knows me to be an honest
broker
and i say uh it was so fantastic seeing
you on the stage i'm so proud of you
all true that was good so this is what
i've started to learn
which is honesty doesn't have to happen
in the moment
it can happen at a later date i still
wanted to answer her question but the
problem was she was so jacked up on
adrenaline
and the timing was too soon that had i
said it now
the delta of her excitement to where i
was going to put her that's what would
have made her upset
so the next day when the adrenaline was
down and her baseline was lower
i said hey can i tell you what i thought
about your play yesterday she goes yeah
i'd love to know and i said you know
what i got to tell you
the script was weak the directing was
weak you know it was wonderful to watch
you but i felt sorry for you
in the middle of it she goes it wasn't
good she could now have a rational
conversation with me
right where the day before there's no
way she could have a rational
conversation with me
so the challenge that i've put to myself
is i have to always be honest but i
don't always have to
make that on a statement in the moment
right but i didn't lie i think that's a
great strategy when dealing with people
but i have to challenge assignment what
happens when you're dealing with a
faceless
system what happens when you're dealing
with a bureaucracy
that is demanding timesheets so when
you're dealing with people
hey that's the way to go because people
are malleable and i think you're taking
advantage of that
simon i don't think you would lie to me
and hopefully you don't think i would
lie to you
but i got a feeling both of us would lie
to a system
yeah and that's part of the ethical
fading is one of the thing is
you said it yourself distance have me
talk to a computer
and put in my id card and digitally sign
it
that's so much easier than you look at
me in the face and you saying did you
like my podcast
and so organizations are faceless and a
lot of times
that ethical fading is so much easier
because we're digitally signing it or
marking i read
your agreement thing in the beginning
that's 23 pages long
i read it and understand and agree to it
sure i'll do that
we've all agreed to everything with none
of us have ever read i know
if they just said i agree and didn't say
i read and understand i'd be fine
but i didn't read it i didn't understand
it but i want my product
so give it to me you know and so that's
what i'm saying
when you're talking person to person
ethical fading doesn't happen as readily
as
put me in front of a kiosk put me in
front of a toll booth
put me in front of something i want
that's just blocking me from getting
something i need
hey i hate to say it we're human now you
got to be careful i'm not making excuses
for lying
i understand hypocrisy
is the word that you used before to
explain this
and it seems to me and i can only refer
to my own lifetime because i
didn't live earlier but if you look at
how divided our nation is
if we sit back in our academic ivory
towers
and you evaluate without putting our own
points of views and political points of
views on what either side is saying
both sides are filled with unbelievable
hypocrisy
and the funny thing is is the attack
that one side makes on the other side is
to point out their hypocrisy
but the hypocrisy on both sides that a
party or a group of people hold two
opinions that are absolutely
diametrically opposed in logic
right but what we say is you're a
hypocrite and it's implied is
and i'm not and i'm not and that's not
true
the answer really is you're a hypocrite
and i'm a hypocrite
and if if anyone could do that if a
party could do that if a group of people
in debate could do that that seems to me
like the most essential starting point
to actually get to
progress and conclusion right because
what's wrong with admitting that we're
human
now some humans are more despicable than
other humans so we'll say let's take
them out of the picture but still
there's nothing wrong with saying i'm
human i haven't let a perfect life
i will find dirt on anybody because i
think they're human too
but and this gets back to the army we
create a type of person that we say
oh an army officer never tells a lie
now they should never tell a lie they
should think lies are wrong
but they should also admit that they're
human because that's part of
self-awareness
but this binary world that we live in i
really love this i mean
simply saying look you're a hypocrite we
shouldn't actually attack the person we
should attack the behavior let's start
there
you know so what you said was
hypocritical
that is pure hypocrisy and we are
hypocrites too just hearing that just
saying those words out loud to you
it lets the pressure out that we can
actually have a rational conversation
now
but you'll never get elected office
simon
or would you yeah that's a good question
is is our society ready for that one of
the hardest places i had this discussion
with
was at west point because at west point
a cadet will not lie cheat or steal or
tolerate those who do
and it is very binary now
what's nice about west point is west
point started saying that is a
very tall hurdle for any young person
and so it used to be that you got kicked
out if you violated that at all now
what they've discovered is that you
could make a mistake and you realize
that a cadet should not lie cheat or
steal or tolerate those who do
but we're not going to kick you out
because that would cause you to lie
about the fact that you did
make a transgression we're going to
offer now discretion we're going to have
you
be developed we'll have you meet with a
mentor and discuss
what happened and we'll work through it
see what we should do is
you're human you aspire to be a person
who never lie jesus feel
and more importantly you aspire and we
will help you exactly and we all admit
lying is not good
the system is designed to help you right
but we're not going to say and the
consequences of you lying are so steep
that
you won't even admit you lie i got this
from your work
that the punishment for telling the
truth was greater
than the punishment for lying right so
if you told the truth i didn't complete
this
it would hurt your promotability but if
you lied you're more likely to get
promoted
if everyone else is lying too then it
makes it easier
so we start creating an expectation that
you have to be perfect
when you're talking about young people
we talk about soldiers when you talk
about employees when you're talking
about children
we have to really think hard if you
expecting them to be perfect
what do you expect them to do when
something isn't perfect
the obvious next step for us to talk
about is well how do we change this like
how do we
combat ethical fainting and what's the
solution yeah i'm just an academic so i
don't come up with
actual answers
but i think you're on to something here
which is the solution
is to turn truth and honesty not into an
absolute but into an ideal a striving
it's an idealism it is still an absolute
okay okay
an aspirational absolute rather than a
current state absolutely
right it's still an absolute it's still
something everyone should try for and
yes
we could draw the line saying no that
was not truthful
so it's absolute but what we can't do is
say
and i want you to surround me with all
these people that never lie
i want you to surround me in a system
that always tells me exactly what i want
to hear
and somehow live in that system because
that's a false world
i think this is where the solution lies
this has to be a striving
or as an organization we say we believe
honesty is important
duh whenever the companies give me their
list of values
and honesty is one of them i always make
fun of them i'm like if you have to
write honesty on the wall you've got
bigger problems
but we believe telling the truth is
important by the way everybody thinks
they're honest first of all it has to be
a verb tell the truth
that's number one because everybody
knows they don't always tell the truth
but everybody thinks they're honest
so tell the truth right number one and
say
you will get punished here more if you
lie about the mistake than tell us the
mistake that if you hide the
indiscretion then tell us the
indiscretion
because if you tell us we can help you
if you tell us we can coach you
we can sit down we can discuss the
circumstances we can figure out
alternatives
if you felt trapped we can work together
to figure out alternatives
especially if it's person to person
because we have solutions for that
right but i think that's what these
systems and organizations have to become
they have to become coaching
organizations rather than judging
organizations
well and i go further is that the army
is a profession
okay and a profession means that we have
these kind of standards
it means that we have these kind of
expectations but it's also a bureaucracy
and it fights between these two
identities the bureaucracy says
tell me everything's okay it wants
statistics it wants
matrix it wants all the measures of the
world is good that's the bureaucracy
kicking in
and what i say is everything that you
said yes that should happen
but organizationally i think we have to
tell
the soldiers saying we will try our
hardest
not to lead
by getting you to tell me everything is
okay
we have to create a safe space for you
to be able to tell me that's supposed to
be what the suggestion box is right
right that's a huge step you're asking
for right that's a huge step you're
asking for i'm an idealist
but i'm just saying the system cannot
rely
on processes and checklists
that you force the person to tell you
everything's okay
because they know that's what you want
to hear they know that you
well-meaningly want to make sure every
soldier drives away in a vehicle that's
been inspected but
don't do it by making the soldiers say
my vehicles have been suspected
do it by making a leader go down there
and check and spend their time checking
and so my solution to your question is
how do we solve this
my answer is leadership what i'm saying
is
leaders if you want to know something
and it's really that important that you
will spend your time checking on it
then go check on it if you want to know
did everyone qualify at the range
then sample 10 of them and you'll find
out did everyone really qualify at the
range
right instead of asking for a roster and
the uncomfortable part of this
is that we discover the lie when the
vehicle crashes and we find out that it
wasn't inspected
and then we find out that the entire
system that we've been relying on for
vehicle maintenance
is all a charade and we go around
it's not just this unit holy mackerel
it's this unit no one's doing this
and why aren't they doing it because
they view it as
ethically fading they really don't want
to know the truth here they just got to
get through this
process to go on leave and this has
nothing to do with military
your career happens to be a military
when you now teach at the military
but this is an organizational issue
right
companies are exactly the same i mean
you look at that 2008 housing crisis
everybody was saying checks and balances
and it's safe and nobody ever checked
right right then all of a sudden
all of them corruption or instability or
broken systems were all revealed after
the whole thing collapsed
of course right because as long as the
charade is working
as long as everybody thinks it's stable
including us then we just
go about our merry way right i call it
mutually agreed deception
you know i'm lying i know i'm lying but
neither of us really care so let's move
on with it it's sort of like remember
the old days
simon when we scored a exit row seat
and the flight attendant will come
around and they give the mandatory talk
and then they say are you willing and
capable and you look at this
76 pound person sitting beside you that
you know cannot lift that exit door if
they wanted to
right right or they don't speak the
language and you know they really don't
know what's going on
and they say are you willing and capable
if you understand everything if so
respond with a verbal yes
and the entire row would say yes and
then you'd say yeah you're right
you know so that's that mutually agreed
deception and that's what we can't
create in organ stations
is that they know we're lying we know
we're lying and everyone's happy because
we love to be
living in this hypocritical world that
we've created
and there's laziness all around right
right the leader doesn't want to have to
go down and
check the vehicles and again it doesn't
have to be every vehicle as you said
it's a sampling you can do samplings or
you can do it randomly
like there are ways around this but i
think the net of this is leadership is
hard work
leadership is hard work and you can't do
everything so if the vehicle's being
inspected is that important then inspect
them but if it's not that important then
think of some
other way it's me and my time sheets
like what my boss should have done has
said simon i know you left at seven
o'clock the other night because you and
i met at six o'clock
so why don't you go back and redo your
time sheets and i say well boss
i don't remember what times i came and
left because i
haven't done these in three weeks he's
gonna say fine i'm gonna let you get
away with it this once
but now i'm checking right are we
satisfied that we have a good solution
here
look the first solution though is admit
that this phenomenon happens
yeah because then we self-regulate then
we say
you know i think i'm starting to
ethically fade here i think i'm coming
with excuses because i'm just trying to
get what i want
so that's at the personal level then we
kick it up to an organizational level
and we start saying
wait a minute am i forcing the employees
or subordinates to lie
on this because i just want them to know
that this is important
and now i'm making them say this so at
the personal level we have to admit it
and then say am i doing it at the
organizational level we have to say to
ourselves am i creating a culture
where i'm expecting people to lie to me
and so
i shouldn't do that leadership is not
always at the top of the organization
being a whistleblower is a form of
leadership
where i'm going to point out what you
are making us do
the system that you've created for
whatever short term gains
is forcing behaviors in this
organization that are unethical
and sometimes illegal and because we
said leadership is hard work i'm going
to be the one to
call it out and tell my boss and say hey
boss i need to have an uncomfortable
conversation with you
the risk is you could lose your job yeah
and that's why i temper that
with saying i don't advocate
whistleblowing i advocate get with your
buddies
and when you go into the meeting you say
let's tell her the truth finally we're
going to tell the truth on this
as a group on this and this but she
doesn't want to hear the truth on this
so we'll just ignore that for now
but on these three things we're going to
go with the truth and if she wants to
tell us to lie to her
we're gonna make her tell us so i don't
go for the whistle blowing because
that'll be the last whistle you blow
in the organization if you do that but
this is very very very important what
you're talking about
which is it is a form of whistleblowing
but there's safety in numbers
if i go into my boss's office i'm going
to lose my job
but if i get together with my colleagues
we all know what we are subjected to and
if we
go in and say this is what is happening
we need you to be aware we're not
accusing you of anything we want you to
be aware of this
and if you want this to continue we need
you to tell us
to lie exactly like i said you
gotta use your wisdom on saying look
she's backed into a wall on this number
it can't be an accusation it has to be a
discussion of what the situation we're
in
and the pressures we're under not like
boss you're a liar you're making us a
liar because then
they're going to dig in their heels and
to openly understand reality okay boss
you need us to lie to you on this one
but on these
i think you could cut us a break because
it'd be better for us and you
if we had a relationship with you
trusted us to tell you the truth
on everything that we could that's the
ideal
because we live in an imperfect system
and we're imperfect people so let's try
to do as best as we can
given who we are and where we live if i
were to summarize what i've learned
on this ethical fading is a real thing
and it is fact we're all human
yeah fact
all organizations are made up of human
beings
so if all human beings are imperfect and
at various times we're all hypocrites
and we lie
then that means that every organization
which is made up of all these imperfect
beings
at various points are hypocrites and
they're systemic lying
institutionalized lying yeah so what we
should do is sensitize ourselves
to what is this phenomenon i do it when
do i do it
i want to minimize that but then there's
a next step in saying and i don't want
to be a party to creating that
environment for somebody else
and i choose to be a part of a solution
i choose to be a part of moving myself
my friends my organization
towards being more honest
more ethical every day and so
when i find myself in the situation i
will be the leader i wish i had
i will gather my friends together we
will lead in a productive manner
make these things known so that we can
as a collective
with our superiors and our subordinates
find a solution
and if our bosses are under such extreme
pressure that they want us to continue
to lie
then at least be honest about the lying
tell us to our face
i want you to lie which most will
struggle to do they will use euphemisms
guys guys i don't want you to lie we
have to hit our shareholder value
of course i don't want you to lie but we
have to complete our requirements
and to continue to point out to the
hypocrisy until either there's a
solution or an instruction to lie
and because the instruction to lie is
way too difficult for someone to give
we hope that they choose the easier
option which is to find a solution which
isn't that what we all want anyway
what you're essentially saying is take
down the facade
the facade of everything's perfect
everyone's telling the truth take that
down and say
okay look this is the way it is this is
reality
let's be truthful with one another it's
really what it is and so
that's not a bad conclusion to this
whole discussion we had simon
lenny from one imperfect person to
another imperfect person
i'm glad that we had an imperfect
conversation
who would have thought we'd get together
and both admit that we're imperfect and
i feel a little bit closer to perfect
in my perfect way today
oh it's been fun thanks for your time i
really do enjoy
talking to you all right take care
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and if you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other